here's what would happen if a new planet
formed in the solar system
it would all start with a gas cloud
entering our solar system the sun's
gravitational pull would cause the gas
cloud to start spinning rapidly
eventually from this gas cloud dust and
rocks would form then they'd start
smashing into each other forming bigger
rocks this is known as accretion this
would continue until some of the Rocks
grew to a few kilometers in size
creating a planetesimal basically the
building blocks of planets as it got
bigger its gravity would start to
attract other large objects throughout
space and watch out with all these
objects flying around some would likely
hit Earth this would continue until the
planetesimal got so big that it
collapsed in on itself and became a
planet of its own a sphere would form
and the silicates would float to the top
it might take over 100 million years but